prime minister justin trudeau is on his
way to rwanda for a summit with
commonwealth leaders the first such
meeting since 2018. from there trudeau
will travel to germany to meet with g7
leaders before attending the nato summit
in spain russia's war in ukraine
expected to dominate all three meetings
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is traveling with the prime
minister david
well they do prime minister justin
trudeau is going to once again call on
world leaders at all these summits to do
whatever they can to get russia to
withdraw from ukraine but world leaders
including the prime minister are also
seized with one of the big problems
caused by russia's illegal invasion of
ukraine global food insecurity mps from
all parties on the house of commons
agriculture committee understand the
urgency of the issue and are already
looking at ways canada might help i
think it's one of the most important
questions that we all collectively in
the world are facing ukraine and russia
are two of the world's largest food
producers
war has not only disrupted that
production but russia is now actively
targeting ukraine's agricultural
capacity and has destroyed some stores
of grain at black sea ports and given
the fact that ukraine
feeds about 400 million people every
year
we know that uh
that the world is is in trouble
we're gonna run out of food but leaders
at this trio of summits the commonwealth
the g7 and nato could struggle to meet
that challenge the world is rather
volatile
and
economic conditions
may make things uh difficult
because if you're looking at a recession
there won't be quite as much money to
hand around this is not just a 2022
problem the consequences of the war are
going to have reverberating impacts far
beyond 2022 and trudeau may face
difficult questions about what canada is
doing to help it is high time for for
canadian farming or canaan
ag to really think differently about
how to support the entire world when it
comes to food security because i don't
think canada's role has been all that
significant trudeau will touch down in
the rwandan capital of kigali wednesday
afternoon and he won't be back here in
ottawa until canada day nitu thanks
david